during the first two months of the
pandemic
panic buying instacart was delivering
more food than walmart america's
largest grocer pretty much second only
to amazon
instacart connects users to local
grocery stores
its biggest competition are tech giants
like walmart amazon and uber
the cart literally is is an app it's the
technology
the way it works is you log into the app
find your local grocery store that's
working with instacart
through the digital catalog you can
choose your items place an order and
within a few hours instacart will
deliver those groceries
right to your front door nearly every
large grocer in this nation has worked
with instacart in some way at this point
really just you know trying to be able
to counteract the scale of
amazon which is now delivering after you
know acquiring whole foods and
delivering in a bunch of different
cities instacart really works
as a digital concierge service
almost for these grocers it is now
digitizing all of their back-ends
running their websites running
e-commerce
for 175 different retailers it's
doing all these different deliveries for
different stores that offer it
and it's growing into probably one of
its
biggest opportunities for its future
which is its ads business
it's running its own marketplace now
where grocery brands and food brands can
pay ads against certain items and
essentially compete with the facebooks
of the world the instagrams of the world
and even google ads in some respects
so um it's it's a super interesting ads
platform honestly
and that's really just in its earliest
days it's only been around for
you know barely a year instacart
has just been inundated with a bevy
of worker rebellions
shortages of food and at the same time
has been raising more money than it
really ever has been
the valuation has soared to seventeen
point eight billion
aforemedia the founder and ceo became a
billionaire in june
after one of the first races of this
year and
it just really seemed like there was all
this momentum but at the same
time there was all this tension coming
from seemingly
every angle i mean porva is
definitely known for his long-term focus
and not getting ruffled by anything
coming his way you know i mean he picked
up the pieces in a few minutes after he
you know found out about amazon
acquiring whole foods which at the time
was his biggest business
and you know through the past year
especially
as other competitors have seen how well
instacart has been doing how much
growth there really is it's just you
know it's
it's been sworn by every which way
there's a question really from a lot
from some grocers
asking who owns their customers at the
end of the day and
instacart you know gives a lot of data
back to these grocers sometimes they
might have trouble reading it and
there's upgrades coming there but
there is a broader question of
is it an instacart customer or is it
the grocer's customer and the groceries
really need it
to be the groceries customer for that
business to be sustaining and
in a lot of ways instacart does too
because instacart needs the groceries to
be sustaining for it to be sustaining
but there is definitely a lot of push
and pull
there happening behind the scenes
you